I know that the coffee edemas are often the best way to detox, are castorial packs the second
best way to detox or foot baths. So understand the seven phases of detox, so castorial packs coffee
edemas are working basically stimulating your parasympathetics and stimulating your liver
to help with detoxification pathways. Coffee edemas are helping with the gut as well, so both of those are
beneficial. There's other things too like sonas can be really good or like I said, just a hot pack over
the liver can be really beneficial. So anything that you can be doing to help with detoxification and
I recommend that you look on the seven phases of detox remember all of our members have access to
all of our courses. This is the course I'm talking about right here at the seven phases of detox
course. Free access to that using the same login that you have with login into the member site,
so make sure you utilize that that goes over all the different phases of detoxification and how
you want to support those. And yes, this person should do another cheek swam. Make sure you said
in a picture of that spot that you were talking about.